all right it's a wednesday edition of
pro football talk live peter king chris
sims mike florio here with you and chris
sims yesterday on his unbuttoned podcast
with paul burmeister did something that
is sufficiently fun enough to make its
way into the top of this hour and that
is an effort in re-drafting the top 10
from 2016. we talked earlier about the
2017 redraft that chris did so now he's
working his way back chris i don't know
how many years you're gonna go back i
suggest you go all the way back to the
year that phil was drafted one a week
every year and let's see where phil
ended up in the top ten in the year that
he was picked but uh this is interesting
and there's some names that jump out at
me
uh not because they're there but because
they're not there but let's start at the
very top and hello everyone out there
who's enjoying the program as we start a
new hour our friends in the uk and
ireland i haven't said hello to you all
in a while i apologize for that but we
were thinking of you and we're with you
and we're glad that you are with us now
look at the very top carson wentz
dak prescott
chris i'll let you defend yourself here
because i think many people would say
that it should go dak prescott then
carson wentz what caused you to put
wence on top of prescott well listen you
you know this i like both a lot you know
i do they're both phenomenal football
players they're both top 10 quarterbacks
in the nfl right now i think they're
both in that conversation of somewhere
between six and ten in the nfl depending
on who you talk to and what their
opinion is
i would probably say carson wins you
know carson wentz to me is just a more
physically gifted player than dak
prescott and i don't say that demeaning
dak prescott he's got an amazing
physical ability too but hey 2017 i
still would have gave my vote to carson
wentz even though he missed the last
three games of the year he should have
been the mvp of football that year you
saw what he did last year with nobody
around him and really putting the team
on his shoulders on a weekly basis and
got that philadelphia eagles team with a
bunch of people where mike you and i and
peter are in the business where we were
watching games going wait who the hell
is this guy where did he come from i
don't even know him so
that to me is why i would say carson
wentz is just a notch better than dak
prescott
peter who would you have taken first
uh i would have taken dak prescott i
would have had chris jones 2 and uh
deforest buckner 3 and then i would have
gone with wentz
um i i a couple of just a couple of
thoughts
i think when you do these drafts which
are always fun to do but when you do
these drafts
i take into account injury
and okay so two of the guys in chris's
top ten i would have in the top ten but
i'd have them both lower than chris has
and that's joey bosa and carson wentz
you know carson wentz has missed 13
games in his first four years
uh and uh the uh
i'm trying to be fair with wence and
bosa because when they play they're both
tremendous talents but to me you know bo
says miss parts of two seasons also so
that has to play a role in and i really
wonder like for instance
what would i have done if given the
choice right now after four years
yannick and gawkway or joey bosa
and and again
bosa on his best day is better but if
he's going to miss a bunch of time
i mean you have to factor that in yeah
it's fair point peter
yeah and you know you're absolutely
right and we don't know how injuries
would have played out differently in a
different team but you've got bosu chris
going to the chargers so it's apples to
apples because that's exactly where he
landed as i go farther down the list i
see jalen ramsey at number four ahead of
tyree kill at number five
mmm
look tyrone killed me
he would have been picked a lot higher
than round five if he didn't have the
off-field issues but now that we've seen
what he can do i don't know how you keep
him behind jaylen ramsey because even
though ramsay started strong you know
just like peter says chris you've got a
factory in the injuries i think you have
to factor in the pain in the butt factor
as well where jalen ramsay forced his
way out of the team that drafted him if
you use that fourth overall pick on him
are you
setting yourself up for that same
outcome where you would have to trade
him whereas with tyreek hill you keep
him around long term like the chiefs
have
well yeah listen i didn't go that deep
down the wormhole but i mean you're
right you make some valid points there
we could also sit here and argue that
you know hey it seems like everybody in
jacksonville like jaylen ramsey except
for one guy and that guy's not there
anymore so maybe that guy was a little
bit of the problem too and you know who
i'm talking about that is tom coughlin
but very close i mean you're right i
mean listen i i i sat here and was going
man jaylen ramsey tyree kill you know
the one reason i took jalen ramsey i
mean jaylen ramsey from get go was asked
and supposed to be like in the
conversation for best corner in football
and he's pretty much answered that last
year was not his best year but of course
yeah he had to move teams and he still
helped out that rams defense when he
went there and i think the other thing
that gave me the nudge a little bit is i
don't think i've seen anybody defend
tyree kill better than jaylen ramsey and
and since tyree kills jumped on the
scene i mean jalen ramsey the past two
seasons uh has given tyree kill some
issues when he covers him man-to-man i
think he's the best at covering him in
the whole sport
you know the peter who's the only
comment i think about
i definitely take tyreek hill uh because
of the pain in the rear end factor i
almost said it uh but wait you guys are
like
killing a lot of pain in the rear like
tyree kills this boy scout now did we
forget last off-season like he's he's
not a pain in the river nothing never
came in that yeah
no charges were filed nothing ever came
in that don't get me in trouble again
chris nothing
with that pain in the rear he still was
a pain whether the charges happened or
not he was still a pain in the chief's
butt last year that's all i'm saying
sorry to cut you off peter i didn't mean
to yeah
all but but the only other point i would
make is that you know nfl teams want
several things out of a draft okay
in my opinion in the first round they
want sure things and they want sure
things at important positions okay there
are two left tackles in this draft
you know laramie tunsil particularly and
obviously ronnie stanley ronnie stanley
you're talking about a boy scout that's
him you know with the ravens they've got
their left tackle for the next decade so
i tend to want to go more with sure
things which is why
i want deforest buckner high i want
chris jones high i want dak prescott
high
and listen you put them in here and i
would put them
one in one a with tyreek hill and that's
michael thomas i realize he doesn't have
the speed and the game breaking ability
but he is the most competitive sob
and also the guy who every day
wakes up and says i'm getting better
today that's what i want on sunday
and that's what i want on monday through
saturday also that's why michael thomas
is right there at number six or seven in
my top ten
yeah and i like the fact that michael
thomas is the second receiver off the
board because he'll still be pissed off
that he wasn't the first receiver taken
he's already fueled by the fact that he
wasn't a first-rounder and my god guys
like laquan treadwell were taken before
him
but uh yeah he still have
he'd have that chip on his shoulder
manufactured or otherwise if he's second
off the board behind tyree kill even
though tyree kill has been good all
right let's talk about some of the guys
who aren't
on the top ten and let's start with the
guy who was the number one overall pick
the player for whom the rams traded up
to get in that move with the titans
to secure jared goff he's off the list
he's gone even though he's got that
gigantic contract which in the rams eyes
validates the decision to go get jared
goff chris why do you not have him among
your top 10 in a quarterback driven
league
well yeah i mean you know hey listen the
rams there was sold on jared goff let's
let's just say they also negotiated
against themselves in that contract they
were like hey jared you won 30 and jared
was like no they're like okay have that
32. i didn't know hey how about 33 and a
half sure we'll give it to you
that's like a common trend in the nfl
right now but you know jared goff again
to me
is is a good football player and again i
you know i hate this i don't want to
talk negative about the guy all the time
because i think people think i'm a jared
goff hater but to me he epitomizes this
arrow we're in right now where we just
go oh the team's good the quarterback
must be one of the best quarterbacks in
football no absolutely not uh jared goff
is a good football player he's a middle
of the road starting quarterback in
football i don't think he's going to be
in my top 16 in football last year he
was ideally number 18 or 19 on my list
when i really got down into it and you
know it goes back to the same old thing
with me you know mike you've heard me
into how i evaluate quarterbacks jared
goff it's about what's there to be had
and when there's nothing there to be had
what do you do with it and to me you
know he's a good player he's got a lot
of things to be successful in the nfl
but a lot of his success is dependent on
sean mcvay's ability to stress a defense
defense out with his scheme and find
completions for him he gets a lot of
silver platter completions especially
his first few years with mcvay last year
we saw people caught up to mcveigh's
offense a little bit and we saw big time
strugglesville in a lot of games with
jared goff because he's just not the
type of physical talent like a prescott
or a wence to when the play does break
down and things aren't there to where
they can still make big things happen
because they have the physical ability
to carry their offense or their team
that way
peter would you have put
i feared goff in the top ten no i would
no i would not although a year ago you
might have and a year from now you might
if you did right
but i think jared goff was a lot better
when he had an effective and uninjured
brandon cooks
and sami watkins because
those are legitimate field stretchers
and chris is absolutely right
this was a team that when it was at its
peak offensively
was uh scheming
you know scheming the heck out of what
they were doing on offense right sean
mcvay and then i think the league caught
up a little bit with them
i i remember that thursday night game
not that you're going to want to talk
about this mike but the thursday night
game against the vikings where he made
two
deep throws in the first half i think it
was like a a 55-yard td to brandon cooks
right in his hands
one step into the end zone it was
utterly beautiful
and that is what you can do when you've
got good effective legitimate speed
and that is what to me the rams are
going to be looking for this year
and with jared goff i look at the bears
at number nine now look deforest buckner
at number nine you got to take him but
when you consider what the bears did the
next year in trading up to get mitchell
trubisky
i don't think either guy is the answer
but i think goff at nine in 2016 would
have been a hell of a lot better and
that's an understatement than true
biscuit number two the next year but i
think the bears would have been sorely
tempted to take goff if he was there at
number nine they were getting toward the
end of their run with jay cutler no
running backs in the top ten here chris
ezekiel elliott off all together and
look the guy had a huge impact right out
of the gates why and he had 1300 yards
last year even though we believe he was
had he was in a down year 1300 yards is
not a down year why is he not in your
top ten
well he i mean again he's really good
derek henry's not in my top ten either
and you know as i sat there and did the
list like i couldn't believe i didn't
put them in there either now i think a
little bit is like the devaluing of the
running back position to a degree but i
think really the big factor is and you
know you guys have hit on it this top 10
list or you know that's basically what i
do like i'm not going back into 2016 and
getting in the weeds of team needs or
anything this is more or less like how i
looked at it as like the top 10 players
from the draft that year but the the
biggest thing is yeah i think the
running back position the devaluing of
that and you know they both have had a
few so-so years in their career but more
importantly these top 10 players are
really freaking good i mean they're at
the top of the league in their position
groups as well just like derek henry and
ezekiel elliott but you know i think
there's more value at these positions
maybe than the running back position
i'm no coughlin i'm no gettleman i am
not taking a running back in the top ten
period end of story it doesn't matter
who he is
i would much rather look where derek
henry went 45 in this draft here's
that's right what's better taking
derrick henry at 45 taking ezekiel
elliott at four or five or saquon
barkley at two you do not take running
backs in the top ten
yeah unless you think it's going to be
barry sanders adrian peterson emmitt
smith and all-time great i mean i think
that's the only time i would do it if i
and how do you know how do you know that
you are getting a guy
where was emily smith
he was he was a top 20 pick something
like that he was a first rounder but my
point is unless you
unless you're confident you are getting
an all-time great that's why i had
hesitation about the panthers taking
christian mccaffrey at number eight and
they didn't use him very much as a
rookie it's like how are you use the
eighth overall pick on somebody who's
going to be on the field and take a
running back later if you're not going
to put the guy out there you've got to
use him to justify that placement i mean
the jaguars with leonard fournette the
bears get all the heat for not taking
patrick mahomes or desean watson the
jaguars chris as you said they clung to
blake bortles in 2017 when they could
have had mahomes or watson now they got
to deal with watson twice per year and
they got to deal with mal holmes for
playoff positioning and post-season
clashes if and when the jaguars ever
make it back there so uh yeah look
yeah i am only taking that running back
in the top ten if i am damn sure he's
going to be a transcendent talent who is
headed to the hall of fame now saquon
barkley may get there and i think that's
why the giants did it but you better be
confident beyond confident that that's
who you're getting any other
names chris that you struggled with who
got left out of this top 10 who you
think maybe could have made it in
well i i don't you know yannick and
gawkway to what peter said i mean again
the pass rusher a guy that can come off
the edge and get after the quarterback
we know how important that is in the nfl
you know jack conklin was in the running
there for a little bit you know the
other names that jumped off to me and
again i don't think they were you know
xavier howard of the miami dolphins he's
one of the better corners in football
you know he wasn't healthy last year so
people kind of forget him but of course
the dolphins made him one of the highest
paid at that position and then hey miles
jack dion jones just to throw out two
other names who deserve just some credit
for what they did out of that 2016 class
i mean miles jack is and dion jones are
two of the the best middle linebackers
in the game and they were one of those
guys that were just on the outside
looking in on this
and you know what the bottom line is
this when we've got guys taken in the
top 10 when you carry that title into
the nfl that can't affect you and for
some of the guys who ended up being
great michael thomas the extra drive he
got from not being a first round pick i
feel like that's part of who he became
and i'd love to see how he would have
developed and how all these guys would
have developed especially the ones who
are motivated by the fact that they
didn't get drafted as highly as they
would have liked to is that a real
factor in your mind peter that if a guy
falls down the board and turns that into
extra motivation that if he ends up
being a top 10 pick maybe he doesn't
have that additional drive
i mean i think that clearly has been the
case with michael thomas obviously it
was the case with tom brady
but i i think mike i think almost every
person who gets drafted let's go back to
chris sims's year
every person who gets drafted thinks he
got drafted too low
every one unless you're picked number
one overall
and so everybody's gonna have that chip
on the shoulder the question is
what are you able to do with that you
know what can you do with that
and what do you do with that and those
are the things that i think really
matter
it mike it's definitely real when you're
when you're drafted not you know when
you're drafted first round and you go to
an organization they roll out the red
carpet they tell you how great they are
they want you to be great because of
course it's their pick and it was an
important pick and there's a lot of
scrutiny and analyzing around it you
know the second third fourth fifth round
pick that guy he wakes up every morning
getting ready for football or practice
or ota is going man they cheated me i
should have been a first round pick the
guy who got drafted in the first round
he's waking up every morning on man i'm
the man i can't wait to go to work and
it's a very real aspect in a player's
mind and motivation
yeah and i think that is the key there
are some first-round picks who aren't
upset that they weren't drafted higher
they they are
allowing themselves to believe they've
arrived when they really haven't arrived
and maybe they don't have that same
drive that they would have if they truly
were upset and and that's the challenge
that's the competitive drive we see it
play out every sunday night when we see
new episodes of the last dance the
things michael jordan did to constantly
motivate him you either have that or you
don't and you can find motivation in
anything or you can't and you'll make
stuff up
if you have to like michael jordan did
when he claimed lebradford smith said
nice game mike to him when he actually
didn't and jordan knew he didn't but
jordan made himself think he did just to
give himself motivation for the next
night it's amazing what the human brain
can do when you're looking for
motivation but you know and and i guess
that's the point the michael thomas even
if michael thomas had been the first
overall pick he'd have found a way to be
upset about it they didn't call me soon
enough they should have used only 30
seconds of time not nine minutes of time
on the clock how dare they not recognize
they should assign me to a contract
before the draft even began whatever it
may be but that the true great ones will
find that motivation in anything or
nothing at all
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports